poussé par la peur d'une nouvelle
secousse les habitants fuient les
régions dévastées d'accord avec jacques
chirac le secrétaire général de l'udps
hier entend conserver son fauteuil
bientôt peut-être l'uranium aussi rare
et cher que le pétrole les femmes
contaminées doivent elles encore avoir
des enfants
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir c'est
vraiment la panique dans le nord de
l'italie dans la région du frioul
maudite des dieux est peu à peu déserté
par les hommes il y a quelques mois
début mai un séisme important vous en
souvenez sans doute avait déjà ravagé
cette province de l'italie est depuis la
7 la terre n'a cessé d'y tremblay plus
ou moins violemment d'ailleurs hier les
secousses ont été tellement fortes que
des milliers d'habitants ont tout
abandonné apparemment sans espoir de
retour
ce dernier tremblement de terre a fait
huit morts et plusieurs dizaines de
blessés les sans abri se comptent par
dizaines de milliers il faut savoir que
le frioul est située sur ce que l'on
appelle une zone de fracture qui se
prolonge jusque dans le midi de la
france
imaginez que depuis quatre mois la côte
d'azur soit soumise un tel chaos naturel
nous sommes ici à jam now plus tôt ce
qui a été dg mena quarles chez mollat
n'existe plus de j'aime n'a été rayés de
la carte
après les deux violentes secousses
d'hier celle de 5h case hier matin et
surtout surtout celle de 11h20 les
habitants de gerona sont partis en masse
définitivement
depuis la première secousse du 6 mai
dernier la plupart des réfugiés de cette
région dévastée du frioul vivent sous la
tente
45 à 50 mille personnes des femmes des
enfants des vieillards div
ainsi depuis quatre mois
avec les secousses d'hier il y a vingt
mille sans abri de plus qu'il faut re le
jeu coûte que coûte avant l'hiver avant
le froid avant la neige
le commissaire spécialement nommé par le
gouvernement italien monsieur lambert
l'ati a pris la décision de
réquisitionner tous les logements
toutes les résidences d'été qui se
trouve sur la côte entre venise et la
ville de gras à dos tout comme jay mona
van zon n'existe plus et après la
journée de terreur d'hier c'est un exode
massif qui a commencé voici le journal
local le messaggero veneto journées
infernales pour le frioul le collier à
l'année lasserre la population abandonne
le frioul démoli à udine la capitale du
frioul cent mille habitants il ne reste
presque plus personne
et pour ceux qui restent chaque nuit est
un nouveau problème des tentes sont
dressées sur tous les espaces verts de
la ville
on dort n'importe où sur les stades
notamment
on doit également dans les voitures on
dormait pour tous mais pas dans du dur
moi j'étais chez moi même
oui je le passé chez moi tout en
longueur est la tête la maison a tremblé
à manière telle que je croyais chine et
depuis vous retournez toujours autant qu
est ce que vous envisagez pour l'avenir
madame vous envisagez pas de quitter ou
dim de même il ya quelques escrocs qu'on
me disait
vie vous venez parce qu'on a invité
n'est ce pas les ans depuis la mort de
gaudi
non je ne laisse pas ma maison j'ai trop
d des souvenirs d'une maison je ne puis
absolument
même si vous devez perdre la vie
j'espère qu'on verra comment de manière
pour moi je vais de suite
j'habite là vous avez peur d'aller
dormir chez vous oui bien sûr j'ai
témoigné ce matin à 5 heures alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé
tout le monde a basculé de la panique
ah s'il ya eu des scènes de panique au
beaucoup et oui 60000 personnes déjà son
parti à cause de ces tremblements de
terre plusieurs dizaines de milliers ont
quitté le frioul ces jours derniers et
cela pose bien entendu au gouvernement
de multiples problèmes car il va bien
falloir loger nourrir réconforter et
donner du travail à tous ces réfugiés ou
plus exactement des exilés car
certainement ils ne veulent plus revenir
chez eux
rude journée
rude journée au pluriel d'ailleurs pour
le premier ministre raymond barre qui
doit à la fois préparer le plan anti
inflation qui doit être rendu public
mercredi prochain tenter de redresser le
déficit de la balance commerciale
française dont j'apprends à l'instant
l'aggravation et qui est passé à 2461
millions au lieu de 1707 millions et
sacrifié à ses obligations de chef du
gouvernement sans parler de la rentrée
parlementaire qu'il doit aussi préparer
obligations du chef du gouvernement
français puisqu'il s'est rendu ce matin
à l'ambassade de chine et rendu hommage
au président mao demain c'est valéry
giscard d'estaing qui viendra signer
officiellement pour la france le livre
de condoléances et montbard continue
donc de recevoir chefs politiques et
leaders syndicalistes et sociaux et puis
aujourd'hui pour la première fois il a
pris contact avec le parlement en
participant à la traditionnelle première
conférence des présidents de cette
rentrée pour établir avec les groupes
politiques
un calendrier des débats de l'exposé du
premier ministre devant les
représentants au sommet de l'assemblée
nationale président edgar faure en tête
nous retiendrons premièrement que le
débat de politique générale débutera le
5 octobre pour s'achever le 7
deuxièmement que le conseil des
ministres devra décider si monsieur bart
demande ou non un vote c'est le souhait
de l'opposition et pour la majorité de
max lejeune réformateur troisièmement
les mesures pour faire face aux dépenses
supplémentaires impôt de solidarité
déficit de la sécurité sociale entre
autres seront examinés à partir du 12
octobre
alors qu'au palais bourbon on se
contentait d'établir un calendrier à
quelques mètres de là le bureau exécutif
de l'ue dr siégeant rude
il se préoccuper de politique et au
premier chef des déclarations de
monsieur chirac et de leurs retombées
diverses et nombreuses
or savez j'étais très étonnée de tout
ces commentaires qui ont été fait autour
de ces déclarations car elles sont
extrêmement sain il rappelle aux
français que dans 18 mois au plus tard
on va travaux élections législatives que
l'enjeu est assez considérable et qu'il
est nécessaire que tous ceux qui
souhaitent que les coalisés du programme
commun n'arrive pas au pouvoir se bat
avec énergie pour gagner les élections
et il met toute son énergie et elle est
grande au service de cette cause
mais enfin quand même ces commentateurs
sont assez unanimes en ce moment ils
disent giscard chirac c'est tout à fait
le même combat
alors voulu dr il va bien falloir que
vous allez choisir soit derrière le prix
en public soit derrière chiens ont je
crois pas que ce choix se pose en tous
les cas aujourd'hui et compte tenu des
termes des communiqués de jacques chirat
higgins est un peu le sentiment que
jacques chirac est en train de prendre
aux places en ce moment il est ce qu est
un général d'honneur il semble faire des
appels aux gaullistes
au delà de vous je crois qu'on soit au
delà de moi voyez je suis très bien
assis dans ce fauteuil et croyez moi j'y
resterai
m
dans son éditorial de l'hebdomadaire
socialiste l'unité monsieur mitterrand
critique sévèrement la propagande du pc
pour les élections municipales dont ils
pensent que le moins que l'on puisse
dire est qu'elle n'a pour objet ni
l'union ni l'unité point de départ de
cette affaire une affiche du parti
communiste affirmant que les trois
formations de la gauche sont d'accord
pour présenter partout des listes
communes dès le premier tour des
élections municipales et monsieur
mitterrand d'ajouter partout cela lui
paraîtra nécessaire le parti socialiste
préservera sa capacité autonome d'action
et d'élections à paris monsieur emilien
amaury propriétaire du parisien libéré
séquestré pendant quelques heures cet
après midi dans son bureau par les
ouvriers du livre cgt des bagarres qui
ont fait six blessés ont eu lieu entre
une soixantaine de manifestants et les
policiers venus dégager l'entrée de
l'immeuble de la fédération de la presse
le conflit du parisien libéré dure
depuis maintenant plus d'un an et demi
aucune solution n'est tanger
le journal le progrès de lyon à 71 ans
est la une d'aujourd'hui la reproduction
exacte du premier numéro datant du 12
septembre 1859 depuis le progrès a édité
quarante mille numéros à la une du
premier numéro il y avait un feuilleton
et un éditorial qui conclut en affirmant
qu'il faut à tout prix préserver la
liberté de la presse un problème qui n'a
pas vieilli comme il est le seul
candidat le président sadate a toutes
les chances d'être réélu aujourd'hui
président de la république de son
premier mandat on retiendra un certain
retour au libéralisme économique
la fin de l'alliance privilégiée avec
moscou contracté sous nasser l'accord
égypto-israélien sur le désengagement
dans le sinaï c'est donc sur le plan
diplomatique que monsieur sadate a le
mieux réussi par contre sur le plan
économique malgré la réouverture du
canal de suez
le pays n'a toujours pas réussi à
décoller l'egypte reste donc un géant
politique et militaire mais un nain
économique
ce n'est pas la première fois sans doute
mais c'est quand même un peu surprenant
les nazis et en particulier les anciens
ss comme les ultranationalistes aussi
font à nouveau parler d'eux en allemagne
fédérale d'abord il y à ce meeting des
nostalgiques d'hitler qui doit avoir
lieu samedi et dimanche averses bourgue
et qui pour le moment est maintenu
malgré de multiples pressions et puis il
y à cette association nationaliste qui
s'est réuni dimanche dernier à cologne
ou plutôt qui essayait cas à la suite
d'interventions multiples et notamment
de l'ambassade de france
la réunion a été interdite réunion dans
le but de créer un mouvement d'opinion
et d'ériger un monument à dachau en
mémoire de yorkin peppers l'ancien nazi
qui tentait de se faire oublier en
france et dont la maison a été incendiée
michel meyer notre correspondant en
allemagne a rencontré le président de ce
mouvement qui considère que les anciens
ss ne sont que d'anciens combattants et
qu'en conséquence ils sont calomnie est
victime d'une propagande anti allemande
et anti nationale c'est tout de même une
argumentation un petit peu difficile à
entendre
elle a aussi mauron ben novick cent de
notre côté on n'assiste pas sur les
pillages de louis xiv en allemagne sur
napoléon 1er qui a transformé l'europe
en cimetière
ou sur l'attitude peu correct de la
france après la première guerre mondiale
ou encore sur les crimes du colonialisme
français
que vous reproche les pays du tiers
monde ou encore sur les terribles
massacres réciproques de la guerre
d'algérie toujours amnistié
naturellement ou enfin sur la terrible
façon sont la résistance la mise à mort
les collaborateurs
le mémorial pepper est une simple pierre
sur laquelle se trouve une croix de fer
il y est inscrit
joachim paper né le 30 janvier 1915
assassiné le 14 juillet 1976 ce qui nous
intéresse c'est le héros de la deuxième
guerre mondiale dans ses activités
militaires et pas dans sa vie politique
il met aussi désagréable de savoir que
pepper a été juste un moment
l'adjudant spin l'air c'est peu
réjouissant mais est ce que nous devons
juger tous les courageux soldats d'hier
selon leurs idées politiques je suis de
ceux qui pensent que de telles choses
doivent être dites que de telles zones
doivent pouvoir legear tour et je le
pense pour deux raison bien simple
d'abord temps que les anciens et les
nouveaux nazis s'expriment librement
on pourra les comptes et les cerner
j'allais dire les avoir à l'oeil
ensuite et surtout ces nostalgiques d'un
passé atroce sont en réalité le meilleur
moyen de nous rappeler que le danger
qu'il représente c'est à dire à mon sens
une véritable déviation de la pensée
humaine que le danger est toujours
présent qu'il est chris dyer et qu'il
nous guette continuellement tenez il ne
gâte pas à l'instant dans ce mouvement
d'intolérance qui nous pousse à rejeter
d'un seul bloc les arguments et les
raisons de l'homme qui vient de parler
bien sûr qu'il existe un sentiment de
culpabilité et de rancoeurs qui se
transmet injustement aux nouvelles
générations d'allemagne fédérale bien
sûr aussi qu'il n'est pas vrai de nier
la bravoure et de sacrifice de quelque
côté il se trouve bien sûr enfin que
l'exécution entre guillemets d'ailleurs
kim paper a été quelque chose de badens
digne d'aussi troubles qu'un vice qu'on
veut tap les vertus reste que beaucoup
d'allemands ne sont pas encore frais
avoir compté quelle peur ils sont
naître en ravivant leurs souvenirs pas
prêt non plus d'admettre qu'ils leur
faut d'abord se taire pour faire taire
les autres demain au brésil on va
beaucoup beaucoup parlé d'uranium et
d'énergie atomique puisque l' agence de
vienne qui en contrôle théoriquement
l'utilisation se réunit en séance
plénière les thèmes sont tout à fait
d'actualité puisqu'il s'agit de la
prolifération nucléaire de la sécurité
dans le travail nucléaire et bien sûr de
la production d'uranium dans le monde
y aura-t-il assez d'uranium pour tout le
monde pourra t'on toujours en contrôler
l'utilisation pacifique et l'arp les
répartition équitable
c'est une réflexion très sérieuse depuis
la crise de l'énergie les ingénieurs du
monde entier se lance dans la conception
de centrales nucléaires pour faire face
à la pénurie et à la cherté du pétrole
et pour faire tourner ses centrales il
faut trouver de l'uranium en france il y
en a beaucoup notamment dans le massif
central le limousin la vendée et en
règle générale c'est uranium se trouve
actuellement surtout dans les pays
industrialisés les états-unis l'union
soviétique le canada et non chez les
producteurs de pétrole
mais quand même il faut continuer à
chercher de l'uranium car les réserves
découvertes actuellement ne dureront que
quatorze années mais pas beaucoup
alors la prospection notamment comme ici
en afrique intensifs elle coûte cher
mais manquait d'uranium ne serait pas
bon marché non plus puis cet uranium
doit être enrichi pour brûlé dans les
centrales actuelles dans des tours qui
se suivent comme celle ci or aujourd'hui
seuls les états unis et l'union
soviétique vente de cet uranium enrichi
la france d'ailleurs se procure la
moitié de ses besoins environ chacun de
ses producteurs pour ne pas dépendre des
autres notre pays c'est lancer la
construction de sa propre usine
d'enrichissement utilisant ces mêmes
tout
avec quelques partenaires dont la
belgique l'iran et l'italie dès 1979
l'usiné du tricastin produira à notre
propre uranium enrichi et comme l'edf
possède près de deux années de stoch la
france ne devrait pas avoir de gros
problèmes de plus pour l'avenir nous
avons décidé le lancement d'une seconde
usine prête à fonctionner en 1985 mais
ailleurs bien des pays risque de manquer
de ces petites pastilles qui font
tourner les centrales alors conséquences
probables
le prix de l'uranium va augmenter on a
parlé il ya quelques jours deux cartels
de l'uranium
la réalité va peut être dépassé cette
fiction vous avez sans doute que
j'espère suivi en direct hier soir sur
antenne 2 l'un des matches de coupe
d'europe sofia saint-etienne qui s'est
soldée vous le savez sans doute par un
match nul plutôt satisfaisant car ce 0 à
0 permet tous les espoirs pour le match
retour qui aura lieu comme les autres le
29 septembre
peut-être les stéphanois ont-ils un peu
déçu tout de même par un manque de
réussite et de l'adresse mais après tout
c'était leur rentrée en coupe d'europe
on verra bien le 29
en revanche nice battu 3-1 par
l'espanyol de barcelone aura bien du mal
à obtenir une victoire par 2 à 0 pour se
qualifier
sochaux s'est assez bien tiré de cette
première épreuve en étant battu alain
bourque part à zéro ce qui laisse le 29
septembre la victoire près possible
le grand perdant de ces premières
rencontres c'est marseille marseille
littéralement écrasé par southampton et
je vous propose tout de suite de voir
les images de ce match très malheureux
pour les marseillais
l'olympique de marseille n'a pu résisté
qu'une demi-heure à la pression des
britanniques 31e minute but de waldrom
migeon n'a absolument plus rien faire et
ce n'est pas fini
l'olympique de marseille voit ses
malheurs commencer les supporters de
southampton n'ont pas fini d'applaudir
34e minute c'est shannon de la tête qui
va une nouvelle fois migeon 2 à 0 on est
au bord du chaos
une minute se passe et la balle va
parvenir à l'ale droite à fisher qui
centre et osgood de la tête marca super
troisième but marseille est complètement
ko petite réaction marseillaise quand
même et sur ce corner c'est waldrom qui
fait une main et l'arbitré va accorder
un penalty suez vient ce penalty qui est
tiré par alonso mais à côté émond a
couru à côté du numéro 10 marseillais et
le penalty est donc à retirer cette fois
alonso change de côté et le guardian
buteur nerfs arrête
décidément le malheur et bien marseille
3 0 cela marqua limites en deuxième
mi-temps 69e minute
rodriguez lance shannon 20 cas le fauche
c'est le penalty qui va être transformé
par shannon lui-même 4 à 0 c'est déjà
terminé pour marseille pour la coupe
d'or les premiers essais du grand prix
motocycliste du bol d'or qui se courra
samedi et dimanche au mans ont été
marquée par un accident mortel gilbert
la vesle semble avoir perdu le contrôle
de son prototype 1000 cm cube kawasaki
est sorti de la piste il été tué sur le
coup les essais ont été immédiatement
suspendu
la catastrophe de seveso en italie n'a
pas fini de faire parler d'elle car on
s'est aperçu depuis quelques semaines
que les conséquences les plus graves
c'était en fin de compte celle du long
terme
imaginez en effet l' angoisse de ces
femmes qui attendent un bébé et qui
savent que le nuage de dioxine qui s'est
échappé de l'usiné chimique peut mettre
la vie de l'enfant qu'elle porte en
danger ou en tout cas le rendre
profondément anormal imaginez leur
angoisse dans un pays où l'avortement
est éminemment blâmable bien sûr il est
toléré dans la région de seveso
mais dans ce pays catholique où la
tradition l'emportent sur la science et
le coeur sur la raison l'avortement qui
pourrait paraître à ces femmes comme la
solution c'est en fait une angoisse
supplémentaires cette femme habite à 30
mètres de la zone la plus contaminés par
la dioxine
elle attend un enfant elle a lu les
journaux elle a regardé la télévision
elle sait maintenant que sous l'effet de
la dioxine elle peut accoucher d'un
enfant malformé handicap est anormal
bobino si même je dois effectivement de
donner naissance à un enfant anormal
moi je le garde ça veut dire que ce doit
être assise je suis convaincu de ces
choses là je ne suis pas d'accord avec
ce qu'on lit dans les journaux
avec toutes les choses qui ont été dites
dans cette situation tragique et sans
précédent on se demande si le courage
cela consiste à accepter ou à refuser
l'avortement du moins toute femme
enceinte de la zone de seveso ne peut
plus douter des dangers de la dioxine
comme dans le cas de la thalidomide on
pourra voir naître des enfants sans bras
sans yeux avec des organes auditifs
défectueux etc
disons qu'il y à un certain pourcentage
de risque les gens temps normal sur 100
accouchements deux ou trois enfants
peuvent présenter des altérations nous
nous avons la certitude basé sur toute
une littérature scientifique et sur
l'expérience du viêtnam que ce
pourcentage augmentera nous ne savons
pas dans quelles proportions
mais ce qu'on sente âge augmentera
sûrement un cv aux adhésions dans toute
la zone contaminée
on a ouvert des centres de consultation
pour les femmes enceintes
il s'agit bel et bien de s'informer sur
l'avortement même si la loi italienne le
condamne et le punit les femmes viennent
ici pour demander au médecin d'évaluer
de préciser le risque qu'elles ont donné
naissance à un enfant anormal
mais cette évaluation n'est pas possible
il est clair dans ces conditions que les
femmes qui décident de ne pas courir le
risque et qui par conséquent veulent
subir un avortement se trouve devant un
problème particulièrement douloureux
elle décide d'avorter
non pas en étant certaine que leur
enfant sera normal mais à partir d'un
doute
notre tâche consiste dans ce centre de
consultation a donné le plus
d'informations possibles et à prendre
acte de la décision de la femme
à partir du moment où une femme a pris
la décision d'avorter
que se passe-t-il car enfin en italie
l'avortement n'est autorisé que dans le
cas où l'accouchement présentent un
danger pour la santé physique ou
psychique de la mère
or dans le cas de la dioxine il ne
s'agit pas de la mère et de l'enfant qui
risque d'être anormal
des situations la question se pose une
question scientifique par une question
cliniques et thérapeutiques et mais
cette question exclusivement politique
et nous désirons qu' il y as pour même
en italie une loi qui le parlement doit
discuter élaborer une loi qu'est qui
permettre à la femme d'un avortement
libre ne votant pas ce que je fais comme
médecin et que si je suis en jeudi qui
est la vôtre la grossesse je n'ai pas
une maladie ce n'est pas une
consécration d'une énorme phénomène est
effective mais au pronostic est la
conséquence du nahd inaction
physiologique et alors là le mécène ne
te bat être le juge d'une situation qui
n'est pas pathologique oui mais dans le
cas de la dioxine
vous pouvez quand même jugé s'il y a
invité mme dahl met dans la machine
mon à mon étude un mécène manche
spécialisation et meurtrier
gynécologique une chirurgie ne peut ne
peuvent pas faire des considérations
techniques
les médecins ne veulent pas décider à la
place de la mère ils ne veulent pas non
plus donner bonne conscience à l'état
qui n'a pas réglementé l'avortement même
à seveso
et puis il faut bien constater que pour
150 femmes enceintes de la zone
contaminée
il n'ya eu puis quinzaine d'avortement
il y a la peur l'angoissé mais il ya
aussi les convictions religieuses très
forte dans cette région minimes terrain
des inputs agresta michel deutsch et
stahl pendant monde pas pour il est
évident que toute cette affaire a été
montée
il faut bien le dire par une certaine
presse qui a cherché à faire pression
sur l'opinion publique pour rendre
l'avortement facile est permissible mais
notre population ne s'est pas laissé
influencer par cette campagne de presse
comme le démontre le nombre réduit des
avortements il est évident que l'église
respecte toute conscience individuelle
qui n'est responsable que devant dieu
mais cela étant dit il faut tout de même
revenir aux principes et il faut
rappeler ses principes
l'image la plus frappante que l'on
rapportera seveso c'est celle de ce
mariage en pleine zone contaminée
on se marie de nouveau à seveso malgré
tous les risques qui ont été évoqués
pour ceux qui y vivent et ce qu'ils
vivront plus tard
un mot du temps avant de terminer cette
édition aujourd'hui l'a fait très frais
sur notre pays je peux même vous dire
que la température maximale relevée à
paris constitue un record c'est en effet
le maximum le plus bas pour à 15
septembre enlevé par la météorologie
nationale depuis 100 ans
lester record demain il fera encore
frais avec des nuages accompagnés de
pluies passagères sur le nord et les
alpes et la corse comme aujourd'hui
il neigera au dessus de 1800 mètres sur
le reste de la france après
débrouillards le matin le ciel se
couvrira sur la moitié ouest avec des
pluies notamment sur la bretagne
il y avait un tiercé cet après midi à
maisons laffitte qui se disputait dans
la 4e course course pardon les handicaps
de la tamise l'ordre d'arrivée les
suivants je viens de l'apprendre 1,2226
plutôt bien d'apprendre le rapport un
tiercé qui rapporte gros d'ailleurs 70
1557 francs 50 dans l'ordre c'est à dire
plus de 7 millions d'anciens francs pour
5 francs à 14000 11 francs 50 dans le
désordre
voilà avec toute l'équipe du journal
d'antenne 2 je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi cette édition et je vous propose
avant de prendre connaissance de la
suite de nos programmes d'en revoir les
principaux après les derniers
tremblements de terre plus de 60000 sans
abri du dr d'accord avec jacques chirac
mitterrand critique vivement le parti
communiste uranium comme le pétrole les
réserves ne sont pas aussi importante
qu'on ne le pensait
dernier un journal vers 23 heures
e
à